[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
Rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting we're gonna be telling
stories from the road
you boys have been traveling a little
bit we've been touring the country and
we've got lots of experiences we've got
lots of experience you know road stuff
yeah the tour mythicality
continues and so as of the airing of
this podcast we're coming off of a live
stream yeah hopefully you were able to
hopefully there were no technical I mean
what ironic will it be if there were
like some crazy technical problem and
that's all we've been talking about last
week no no no maybe if I talk about it
now it'll jinx it won't happened
the other thing well in and then if you
you know if you didn't watch the live
stream there's still other ways that
we're we're packaging the lack of the
the to the the stage show that is the
tour mythicality which I think we're not
gonna call the tour mythicality at that
point we'll call the thing something
real catchy well we know what it is you
don't want to say no okay that's fine no
if you watch the show you can you can
infer what it is it's a stage show slash
comedy show I don't know why I'm talking
about it but we're gonna be telling you
some things that have happened to us in
the course of traveling together for a
couple of trips so because cuz as of the
recording of this we've got a couple
under our belts been in New York been to
Texas and we're still gearing up for
that San Francisco San Diego la leg of
the tour but yeah we'll get into that
but first I just want to give a health
update yeah since you know you've given
a lot of health updates and I love them
I'm sure you do I can't wait to hear
your health updates right can I give you
one I I'm all ears I hurt my back
brother and you weren't there for me I
went to the gym this was two morning's
ago
and I'm in the gym and I'm down on all
fours and what they call the beast
position and on your hands and knees and
then if you lift your knees off the
floor so your feet who calls it the
Beast position the instructor just your
instructor or instructors worldwide I
don't know I didn't ask him that I
thought that'd be insulting now did you
make up that name I think they did
that's my fear on you're never heard get
on your hands and knees with your with
your toes on the ground - and then well
the beasts position push with your toes
so that your knees come off of the
ground and it's a really good core
workout when then you drag a bag across
the floor underneath your torso just
like a beast just like a beast known
worldwide yeah beast dragon bags
worldwide and then man I am up - legit
status but he got like a 60 pound bag
what are we talking 70 no it's I
extended my right leg out straight
what's that three-legged beast yeah it's
the three-legged Beast you need that you
need to be consultants for them to
certify the normal name all your
positions it made it difficult yeah and
then something tweaked in my back like
not on the spine just to the right
definitely muscle like mid-back mid-back
mid way it feels in it you got these
muscles in your mid-back that you just
feel like there's no way I could
activate them right now just like an
unnecessary muscle but it can actually
really Nessus
muscle going over the rib cage kind of
kind of thing I didn't think too much of
it I'd in pride creeps in very quickly
because I didn't want to stop yeah I
gotta keep going so I kept going and
then right after that I'm gonna do some
squats with two kettlebells so I'm like
what position is that
I take that just the kettlebell squat
squatting hitting squatting hen
squatting hit the egg layer later I
scoop up these two huge kettlebell I
mean huge 7fd I'm talking like 130
pounds each I'm like and I have him
under my I've scooped my elbows
underneath in my my thumb's are against
my collarbone just like he told me and
then I start squatting to lay another
egg this Chad tells me and then I
coming back up I'm like ooh that spot
now it's really hurting and I dropped
the kettlebells and I'm like you tapped
out I tapped you I can't I've done
something brother
hmm I can't keep going and then I would
I did some stretches and tried to he
showed me he there was a correlation
between the back and the hips and I was
like I'm too far gone man
I did some hip opening stretches he
tried to loosen you up but then I just I
had to leave him defeat I had a hard
time leaving by the time I got home I
felt like I couldn't walk stiffens up
and I started to get really scared
because you've made me paranoid with all
of this stuff you've been through it's
scary stuff man you could you've been
debilitated for months or months at a
time and I knew that it wasn't like
skeletal related skelet are related but
I was still kind of panicking and then I
come in and we got to shoot some stuff
and I mean I just feel for you I know I
know what it's like to be in a horrible
mood cuz your back hurts I mean it's
like I did it stuff man could you tell I
was in a bad mood well you weren't there
for me because I texted you on the way
huh on the way come on happy because you
were coming to pick me up to carpool oh
I pull out to your house link comes out
with yeah like he just looks like he's
just forlorn and he's got kind of bent
over and stiff right he's got what looks
like the kind of bracelets you would
wear when your move helping somebody
move and you have it like up around the
middle of your back like kind of riding
your nipples get my text and for some
reason I didn't I don't ever since that
frickin phone update our phones don't
work at home the glooms seed has
germinated they want us to upgrade to
the next phone that's what they want us
to do and you know what I'm gonna do I'm
a freaking up i'ma buy the new phone you
have to because the operating system
here's what happens this is a conspiracy
and but I fully believe it I mean way
back we wrote the iPod dead iPod song
and we talked about the doom seed it's
in there but what it is is the
programmers get all excited about the
latest and greatest technology and what
they can get their phones to do with the
new software they're testing at having a
grand old time and
I'll tell you that they test it on old
phones but do you really think yeah that
there's a guy at Apple he's like on the
old phone guy yeah I'm gonna I don't
even have a frickin old phone I have the
previous version they are never going to
spend any amount of their own personal
time experiencing the trauma of running
the newest operating system on an older
phone because they dress frustrating
they've got us trapped it frustrates the
crap out of us so it's gonna frustrate
the cracker pie of crap out of them so
they're not gonna do it ya know to get
the new phone and it's just to be normal
people and you know what no one there
and I'm not just talking on Apple I'm
talking I'm sure it's everybody every
every every company that has software
and hardware they do it on they embrace
it they don't do it on purpose but they
just let it happen because it benefits
them for the software to go beyond the
hardware to require the purchase of new
hardware to keep up yeah that's why I
didn't get your text long status your MC
I usually I used to get your text from
my house to your house but they put up a
virtual wall between our homes now and
then the text I don't mean we don't read
the text don't work anymore the text
said hurt my back you any come comfort
me anything you can do bring or advise
do it like I was expecting braces shots
drugs I didn't know what what all you
had I have all of that but I wanted all
of it but I did I do carry and you came
with nothing
no no so I carry a brace in my backpack
so I did have that but she already had
that great looking nipple brace I
thought oh sh t yeah that was more than
enough you're wearing your corset I
thought corset yeah you look great but I
also discuss with my court it could have
worn it under my shirt by the way but I
kind of felt sexy I didn't give you my
brace because my brace is really ready
it really isolates the low back and you
were kind of having a mid back problem
so I just didn't think it would be of
any help to you but and also you listen
I mean you I'm glad you mention that I I
went out of my way to when you were
complaining about it to be like to not
say you know I felt exactly the way you
for weeks on end like seven times over
the past decade I don't what but I but I
didn't say anything because I was like
you know what that's the worst thing you
can say to somebody who's currently in
pain is what is to say well you know
what I know exactly you feel I mean I've
had that pain a lot more than you have
oh you know I knew that you know that's
you don't want to say that to somebody
but I don't feel like I complained that
much no you didn't complain that much
but you were very affected it but I
completely it's such a distraction when
something yeah that core
first of all any pain if you had chronic
pain I really feel for you because it
becomes this distraction that I mean I
do think you eventually get better at
dealing with it it makes good television
if you're like house you remember that
show mm-hmm that was good for a number
of seasons because of his suffering but
especially buddy system season one I had
crazy back issues the whole time season
two I had him for like a week but like
it yeah it sours everything so I'm glad
you're doing better you're not wearing
the corset anymore I'm doing better
because I went to Avon physical
therapists who also my physical
therapist Christie is friends with her
so then she was able to like come in
early before we had to shoot GMM and so
from 7 to 8 o'clock I swung by there and
she put me in these poses and holds it
was weird I need to go name those
positions because it's true she does put
you in a lot of positions well cuz I was
expecting to lay down and have her like
massage the spot and I understand that
different parts of your body connected
so like she might like manipulate the
hips
grab your ear you know I mean it's like
she's like you know that the back is oh
your back hurts oh let me get the ear
love your left eyebrow let me massage
that she there's lots of connections
that she finds but at one point I was
sitting up with my arms with my hands
clasped behind my neck like like I'm
showboating and then I'm shirtless shirt
off huh yeah cuz you got to get well
very early on I had a shirtless so that
she could like right yeah you know
there's no reason to have a shirt on
when your your muscles are being
specifically manipulated in your back I
mean put that on a t-shirt my hands are
clasped behind my my bare neck and then
she's behind me hugging me from behind
that wasn't part of the treatment and
then her thumb is like in my sternum and
then she told me to turn to the left
lower my right arm my right elbow a
little bit she's behind me she's looking
at the ground and then she's like
squeezing and doing these like subtle
thing I don't it's just I I didn't feel
like anything I felt like I was posing
for a weird art project he doesn't feel
like I was like it's somebody painting
us right now yeah through that little
people she'd be like it's drying right
look to the left a little okay now relax
and I would be like oh yeah he does the
tensor like minuscule stuff that if
somebody walked in on it it's not that
you'd think it was inappropriate you
would just think it was about guard
mm-hmm like Wow
but she's charging a lot for that
performance art and she was she does but
you know what I feel better that's the
things I lied some wet heat on my own
time little hot tub action baby wait now
I used to because I I'm a skeptic right
so when she first started like doing
that stuff to me when I was dealing with
my because I've got like the back thing
I've got hip things I've got knee things
I'm a mess she does this stuff in like
the first like three months I was just
like
this is BS that's what I'm thinking but
I'm also like I'm just gonna give it a
chance and I got to say that it it
whatever I don't know how all this works
but the stuff that she showed me to do
that she did and the stuff that she
showed me to do which is well there
stretches but there's like getting
certain muscles to be too like basically
to increase the mobility of certain
parts of your body and then how it's
like across your body and yeah yeah this
shoulder and related to this thing
getting all that moving like it my back
is so much better than it's ever been
don't say it however jinx it however I
do currently have it pulled but muscle
but I think but it's definitely not it's
not it's not hurting right now but it's
just like somehow I pulled my butt
muscle in my Pilates class oh but it
wasn't I don't know but that on the TV I
don't know what to do I thought about
calling Yvonne but then I was like
that's gonna be a weird session because
there would be a lot of glute Masashi
which personally I'm into but I mean
that does get even more awkward we
should live stream these treatments to
defray some of the cost and the
awkwardness if you know that like
hundreds of people are watching maybe
more I think it actually is better for
everybody I think there's some sort of
like your glutes not exposed I think
there may be like a HIPAA situation if
you isn't that the health people I don't
think you can I don't think you can come
out a hip let you just set it wrong like
medical situations like there's no
doctor that livestreams his meetings
with his patients because it's like
violates some laws I think the bottom
line is I still feel a tinge of pain but
I'm on the mend it was just you know
it's just a pulled muscle it's kind of
deep no issues there long term well I'm
glad you're back link no pun intended
yes let's take a moment to let you guys
know about some merch that we are very
excited about shirts if you're into
origins this is our friendship origin
t-shirt rhett and link established
oh nine oh four 84
these are actual photos of us on this
picture on this well they are pictures
on this t-shirt cute us get this a
mythical dot store get this that's gonna
that's justice that's their salesman
right there
get this selves itself you can also get
this this is the well official this is
the creature that was birthed in the
book of mythicality ever gets lost never
gets lost it's going to be created one
day using CRISPR technology if we have
anything to do with it also available in
mythical does store we was the reading
this morning that they've got a crisper
Pig now that is crispy your pig no a
lower fat pig made via crisper well you
want a lower fat pig I do not know but
it's it it happened in China hmm I got a
crispy or pig in China should look out
for that thanks for supporting internet
teaming and repping your love for us
let's just be real about it reppin you
rep us but we're also trying to create
more stuff that's not just about like
hey I'm a fan of yeah this it's more
like that's a cool shirt
I shared you know that's cool too for
things if you think that's cool to put
it on your body okay so we're gonna talk
a little bit about our travels one of
the funny things one of the really funny
things that happened as we were getting
ready to leave for this most recent trip
that we've had as of the recording of
this it was our Texas trip yeah and we
had a car come pick they picked you and
Christy up and then they drove to my
house and pick me and Jesse and then
drove us all to the airport so we didn't
have to leave a car at the airport
and so let me just say that like we're
sitting in this SUV at the bottom of
your driveway because it's like a you
can't rather yeah you have a steep
driveway so the guy wouldn't drive up
there I told him not to so we're just
parking down there at the bottom and
then we're waiting for you and waiting
for him they're almost done I look in
the rearview mirror and I see there's a
guy standing behind the SUV he's not
immediately behind
he's like I can see his full body and I
can see that he has a dog at his foot
that's sitting there yeah and there he's
staring he's not he's not looking to and
fro he's not looking at his dog he's
staring at one point up your driveway
mmm that's what he was and it took me a
while to figure it out but I was like
he's looking like a statue
an angry statue and he was looking up
your driveway and then I told Christie I
was like that dude and then that's what
that's all i that's as far as i got
before you started coming out enjoying
life so when i got to the bottom of the
driveway and i saw him I knew who he was
and I knew what he was upset about
because I could tell that dude was upset
you know how when someone's upset in
their eyes water like I could tell from
a distance that like well he was mad
crying yeah he had a little mad cry like
his eyes were wet I was like I'm not
getting out of this car he was oh he was
livid
but I thought that he was resting his
dog I didn't know if he was like if his
eyes were sweaty cuz it was like a hot
day I didn't you know I didn't know well
let me just give some background so I
share a property line with this man and
what part of the property line is a
fence that he has a fence and I have a
fence and the fences there's like a six
inch gap between defenses no no issues
there but I will say that the way I got
to know him was is that my kids were
playing basketball we have a little like
basketball goal on the side of it next
to the house and it's easy to lose your
ball over into their yard mm-hmm and so
like the second day that we were there
like Shepard shot the ball over there
and so I sent the boys over there
because I thought that was cool you know
send your kids over to the stretchers
house to get the ball back to be like
hey we're new to the neighborhood and my
balls over there just so that they would
get into the habit of throwing the ball
back over which happened for a while and
and you don't want to be the one to have
to go fetch the ball every time right
right yes I wanted to be like hey we got
the basketball goal okay you know I know
the previous owner didn't have like kids
that were using it a lot but we are
gonna use it a lot we're probably on a
lot of our balls are gonna be up in your
business
so didn't you sent him over to have that
conversation without you yeah and then I
do remember my boy saying that it was an
interesting
I don't remember specifically what they
noted but it I noted that it was they
said it was a kind of a different they
didn't they weren't super warm to the
boys okay
interesting but but then the lower part
of the yard they have like a lot of
vegetation in their yard then I have
like a lot of vegetation in my yard and
they kind of just come together but
there is a clear property line
however right at the bottom of the
driveway there's like this little thing
that kind of juts out where I'm sure the
property line doesn't jut out but it
kind of seems like the bottom half of
the driveway is kind of like almost
going into his property line and there's
like a bush down there next to the side
of the driveway so from a landscaping
perspective it feels like the previous
owner had landscaped around the driveway
and then when the driveway dogleg table
but so did the landscape it feels like
the landscaping is in my territory like
even though it's in his it's definitely
in his yard so when we decided we were
gonna do some landscaping and Jesse
specifically had the idea to put like a
palm tree on each side of the driveway
oh we went and talked to him okay and it
was gonna require cutting back this Bush
a little bit now first of all I you've
seen his yard this guy it's like a
forest it's like it's not intentional
it's but it's I mean I like it it's very
natural there's nothing I dislike about
it but it's it's not manicured but it
doesn't make not what I'm about to tell
you does isn't really consistent with
the way the yard looks okay so when
Jesse talked to him he was like he said
Jesse was like can we cut the bush back
a couple of feet so I can plant this
palm tree and he was like why would you
cut the bush the bush is a living thing
that was sign one that this is a little
interesting a living thing yeah well why
do you cut grass dude cuz it I mean we
cut living things all the time it's just
part of trim ug no let's use the
exercising our dominion over the earth
so but eventually he you weren't gonna
pull up the bush you weren't gonna no no
we're gonna kill the bush
it was just cutting it back a little bit
so we could plant what I thought was a
very pretty tree to match the other side
of the driveway
in other words this is beautifying the
space that's two years ago Oh haven't
talked to the dad to the guy since oh
wow right that was ever back when we
moved in and so let me guess did that
kind of have a dog yeah but the other
day it's like through four days before
the day that we got picked up to go to
the tour I had asked my gardener to trim
some bushes and there was specifically
one that was growing over the sprinkler
and it was causing the sprinkler to just
hit the bushes and not actually go on to
the ground cover that needs to be
watered so it hit one living thing but
it was depriving another living right
and so I was like I have to cut one
living thing to let another living thing
lift you got to make sacrifices
right I took a saw I found a saw it's
the trolley problem and I went right
actually because I know that my neighbor
is sensitive to these things I basically
just went to where the property line is
and I just cut the limbs at
approximately where the property line is
so that you know I this this kind of
this tree slash bush was just invading
my yard so I just cut it and then I did
cut a couple of other limbs that were
making their way all the way out into my
yard I kind of cut them a little bit
further in whatever but then I actually
ended up with a lot more put branches
than I anticipated and then I the only
place because of the slope of my yard
the only place that I could set them
down was it on the curb in his yard but
you you've seen his like his house is
way his driveway is way turn around the
corner I don't even have those way up
there I've never seen the house right
his house is way up there up this hill
and this is more in my domain even
though it's on his property but I was
like I'm gonna set these branches here
and then I'm gonna text my my gardener
and just say hey could you I can't fit
these in the in the been the bend can
you take them but I didn't do it
immediately so what he was so pissed
about was the fact that I had these
limbs in his yard and he's standing
there with his dog and he's like what's
the first thing he said
but it was something like did you what
is this what is this and I was like oh
man I'm I am I'm sorry about that
I actually and this is 100% true I was
like I just texted my gardener to come
pick that up today cuz that was true cuz
I'd done it before cuz we were leaving I
was like I got to get his stuff out of
this guy's yard it was just on the curb
it was barely in his yard but then but
then he was like baloney hey who says
baloney and when I hold up you got
belonging yes I'm in and I was like do
you want to see the text he's I don't
want to see the text and then he says if
you want to cut a tree on my property
you talk to me and I was like well I cut
it at the property line it was stuff
that was coming he says if you wanted
and then and then all of a sudden he
went to the palm tree he said in that
palm tree that's on my property you have
one day to take it down oh wow and I was
like well I'm about I'm actually leaving
to go out of town right now he says I
don't care you have one day to take it
down and if you don't take it down I'm
going to chop it down and put it in your
driveway and I was like great and I'm
watching all this from the SUV I'm like
man I should be didn't think about now
I'm sorry you know me now if this course
we've talked quite yes it was in the car
with us we've talked quite a bit on this
podcast about how we both handle
conflict and we've also we wrote a whole
chapter in the book about it now if if
this guy confronted you you would you
would have been livid like except you
would have been mad super mad and I was
but I was definitely the conversations
we've had here and I would hope that I'm
a changed man and I would have kept my
cool I would have done some deep belly
breathing and then I would have diffused
the situation here's the thing about the
way that I approach these situations I
actually was not mad at all I wasn't mad
at him at all it's like my first
instinct was uh I was it was disbelief I
was like is this guy really this mad
about this is he really saying this is
he really threatening me in this way
yeah and then when they say baloney and
then I said my second but the second
thing I was thinking was
do i defuse this situation right here
right now and get this guy to back off
like so I was like you know as soon as
we get back we should have a reasonable
conversation about this and he was like
reasonable my ass or something like that
yes and just what he was like one day he
wouldn't in the US before he walks off
he said something about I made a
judgment about you right he said what
I'm sure you're some really special
person and I was like what is he talking
about and I think I think he said I'm
sure you're so wonderful you're so
wonderful so what he said what what he
was well again I heard him this may be
me projecting onto this guy but I have a
feeling that because he has teenage kids
I have a feeling that they know they
know that I'm a youtuber and so they
probably have said something like yeah
he's like YouTube famous or whatever of
course that doesn't mean anything to
this guy and so I think that it's sort
of this like or maybe he could just okay
no but the way that he said it was very
much like you think you're so special
because you're my kids think you're
somebody or something like that and I
was like what does that have to do with
anything you don't believe me that I'm
gonna get this stuff picked up I tried
to defuse the situation so but then I
was kind of he walked off we get in the
car and then both me and Jesse are both
kind of shaking up shaking up and I'm
like thinking how are we gonna defuse
this like I got a I'm gonna like we're
like figuring out a strategy for what
we're gonna do when we get back like
what it is right take them a bottle of
wine or something that's cuz I really
want to go I here's here's the thing at
first it's like my observation was
because you were verbally processing it
with me and Christy you and Jesse and at
first it's like well how do we resolve
this what I mean
the babysitter's taking care of the boy
she needs to drive out the driveway are
they going to be able to move the palm
tree out of the way if he thunks it down
right there and so and it's like how do
we defuse the situation but then I
noticed a shift in your mindset by the
time we got to the airport
you were saying things like I'm going to
go to his front door when we get back
with a bottle of wine and you had
shifted your perspective you're your
objective had changed to a much higher
goal I want to become friends with this
man in order to well hey I want my palm
tree to be there and I wanted to be okay
with it
well I think that's now see I think a is
you want to I was gonna say kill him
with kindness but you don't want to kill
him no I mean honestly it's just I don't
be I wanna with the wit you want to win
and what would define winning well
winning is having him to no longer feel
this animosity no but it was more than
that what you want is you want to win in
such a way like you're so nice to him
that he has to be nice to you
what he wants is he what he wants and
then when he wants me to be mad back at
him yeah so when you're not your goal is
for him to have to be nice to you and
say dang he's he's taking the high road
and then go back into his house close
the door and say what and be really mad
that he's not mad at me but and so that
you have the power over him uh well I
mean and I'm not saying that's a bad
thing I'm saying that's winning when you
can be so nice to the guy that a your
palm tree stays and B he has to go in
his house and grumble to himself but he
can't do it to you anymore because
you've taken away his ability to say
things like baloney you think you're
wonderful like he can't do that to you
that's the power that you're taking and
I do also think that like it's just to
have a neighbor when the basketball goes
over he comes out of his house goes
downstairs grab the ball throws it over
and says something nice to your kids
well sure that would be great I think
the thing that I that I want him to
understand and that I would say to his
face and hopefully we'll have the
opportunity to is like with all the crap
that is going on in the world and all
the conflict that there is are we really
having a fight over this don't we both
want the same things we won't beautiful
yards it's just like the steps that I'm
taking that have caused these problems
are all because I'm trying to beautify
the situation right it isn't because I'm
trying to exercise some sort of
authority over your property and also I
did get all the limbs off within the
hour
I actually called instead of texted I
called my gardener I said I've got a
situation with my neighbor I want you to
give there as fast as you possibly can
and get this stuff out of there because
I want to show him that I actually mean
what I say and that you were getting
this stuff out there and you might need
to bring a bodyguard with you and when
we got back home Sunday the palm tree
was still in its place so that actually
took a little bit of the wind out of my
sails of like I was also super tired
which we'll talk about like when we get
back from a tour stop on a Sunday it's
like there's not a lot left and we took
we took Jesse and Christy with us on
this last trip so I did all this you
know energy that I had around
reconciling was kind of like I just
don't want to do that right now and the
limbs are gone and the palm tree is
still there so I'll do that later but
every day that passes it becomes less
likely that I'm going to try to rectify
this situation well I thought I still
feel like you have to you you did you
you removed the shrubbery no but I won't
reconciliation yep your palm tree I want
reconciliation what if something happens
man what are there's an earthquake what
if we need to rely on each other and
what it's just like no we hate each
other because he threw some limbs on my
yard at one time I mean in what your
wife said is an interesting perspective
when we got in the car she was like I
just feel sorry for that man because he
feels that way all the time he's mad all
the time and you just happened to be the
target at this particular moment there's
a lot of people who just lived that way
if you're mad like that then it's a
lifestyle you're live you're waiting for
the next person to piss you off that you
can unload on them and it's just such a
sad sad way to live it doesn't I don't
understand where it comes from and I'm
sure he's got all kinds of stuff on his
plate whatever but it's just why why why
why is this the way that he's choosing
to deal with this I don't know hopefully
I'm gonna be able to
change that and you know what we hadn't
even left your driveway yet that's
that's the type of adventures that that
we that are in store for us as we as we
continue the tour you know because I
didn't know what to expect you know from
basically every other weekend sometimes
weekends in a row like devoting our
weekend showing up at a city on Friday
doing the show then getting up the next
morning traveling to a nearby city doing
two shows back to back and then getting
up early the next morning and flying
back home
I just didn't know having committed to
it what it was gonna what it was gonna
feel like and I think it is very
exhausting it is also very rewarding to
to to meet you guys on the tour and to
see so many faces and to have a live
interaction that's not across a screen
at the and then we we end every show
with a QA and we're able to like have
more of a conversational back and forth
with the audience it's it's it's great
I'm so glad we're doing it but it is
also very exhausting and there's not
really anything ultimately there's not
anything besides the tour but it's like
it's all about the shows
well there's Ravel yeah the shows and
then the the sleep that we can afford to
get and in between shows I mean just
trying to preserve any energy you have
or like recharge in such a way that you
can give it your best mentally and
physically but we're not really doing
that because in between the two shows on
Saturday at least the last two weekends
we've taken that time to go to a local
bookstore and you know we've been
Instagram storying this stuff yeah the
whole the whole idea is that we we go to
a place where the book of mythicality is
we take a Polaroid of us holding a book
our book and we put it into one of the
books and then you you guys find it yeah
someone who's in the area and in in
New York at the Barnes & Noble we did
that and we we we met a couple of fans
in there but they didn't see us like
hide the thing so we did get out of
there and then we got back and we did
the show and then after the show one of
the guys who was in the VIP line like
the meet-and-greet you got to meet us
brought out the book and he had gotten
the book and he was like I saw that the
instant story and I like ran five blocks
to what I thought was the Barnes & Noble
and I found the book yeah he found it he
did find a fan and he brought it back to
us
and then he asked us to sign it and I
took that as an opportunity to keep it
well he'd already signed it know will we
signed a Polaroid no but we had signed
that was the weird thing no I didn't
keep it he kept it but that's the thing
that's still the mystery that I thought
about later is that he had the book with
the Polaroid sign taped exactly the same
way that we had taped it inside there
yes and it was signed but the book we
signed in the bars and Noble but the
book he had was not signed I still don't
understand what happened I think someone
at Barnes & Noble
took found that book and then took the
polar it out and and taped it to another
book so that there would be two books
with something valuable to a fan in him
that's what I think altruistic aliy
someone distributed the signatures so
now there's a signed book and a signed
Polaroid in another book that's what I
think happened but then when we were in
Texas in Dallas we had the two shows in
Dallas so we typically do one show on a
Friday night and then two on a Saturday
and we drove from Austin to Dallas on
Saturday morning and then in between the
shows we were like we're gonna go to a
Walmart because the book is being sold
at Walmart and for some reason the
closest Walmart we could find was like
20 minutes away maybe more than that and
so we drive on and so we're also gonna
go to a water burger because everybody
is telling us that you guys Texas you
got to go to a water Berg everybody's
like you got to go and you got to say
whether or not it's better than in and
out it's really okay in between the
shows let's go do that
and we in wishfully we thought we would
also be able to take a nap that
never happens so again all this is on
Instagram was on Instagram if you follow
the stories but I mean first of all
Whataburger we tried that it is not in
and out yeah
sorry Texas we did say that on Instagram
but it is but it is no in and out but
now whenever idea in and out I'm like
what a burger does a great burger
you have taken the slogan yeah I mean
they you know they got so many things
they're trying at Whataburger yeah it's
the way that's a sign the way you put it
was as they were kind of going the
Arby's route which I think they're
actually going the Carl's jr. jr. yet in
that again
specialty burgers that like are fleeting
but they're there for a month and
they're gone oh this was yeah the guy
but to me to picture reason my person
out to your personality in and out is
like the bullseye it is that we do three
things
yeah we do burgers fries and milkshakes
and we do in the same way and we've done
it for 50 years and it'll never change
and they broke don't break it that is
your bullseye now I appreciate that and
I love those burgers but I also do
appreciate like oh we got a catfish
burger you know it's like what we some
new yeah yeah there's something new with
a bunch of different weird ingredients
don't like they're searching well yeah
but I mean every once why you hit a
bull's eye I mean time I give you a fart
and in one of those games it helps you
write four darts four darts are better
than one right you know I get really I
gave you two farts in you one it's a
weak analogy I think it's pretty strong
but I do I mean we got the normal burger
and it wasn't great then we well the
probability I was left or right cuz we
were in Texas well the problem with
doing that many different things is that
if you're gonna stack up the variety of
one restaurant against the restaurant
who does one thing that's not really an
apples to apples comparison at that
point because if you like variety you're
like why don't wanna eat the same burger
every time but if you're just doing we
just got the water burger straight no
frills they had no they had like a
chorizo burger and a chili but we didn't
we said no to that when would you say
straight what burger it just wasn't a
great it wasn't bad
it was like I was satisfied
as a meal but I don't choose to eat a
lot of burgers at this point in my life
it's a yeah and I wanted to really count
when I eat it and then we trotted across
the street to the Walmart and literally
spent 15 minutes just trying to find the
book section of the Walmart gracious I
had been in a Super Walmart a long time
and then once we found it it was at the
front of the store we literally did a
lap around the whole Walmart boy that
was exhausting yeah and then we get back
up there and they've got more romance
novels and you can shake a stick at yeah
but they did not have one book of
mythicality now they did at one point so
that's that made me feel kind of good I
know that they had them there because we
called ahead make sure they would have
one but that but then it was gone so
they were sold out at the Walmart and
also they say this was interesting I
mean to me at least is that the people
of walmart don't really have anything to
do with the books that are on the
shelves it's just there's like a there's
like under there's a vendor who comes in
and just supplies the books and lots of
places like I've seen lots of the beasts
taking pictures Target Walmart elsewhere
where they just have like a handful of
books like that's not gonna happen as
readily it like a Barnes & Noble that's
a book store they got more of a stock
but some of these places that just have
a book section they might have 10 books
and those 10 books at mythicality are
getting sold so quickly that so many
places don't have them I mean hopefully
that's that makes me feel good but the
problem was we're in story right he said
this whole search because we're like oh
we're gonna go we're gonna find a book
we're gonna sign it we're gonna take the
polar we're gonna put it in it we're
gonna get out of here and then by the
time we were like insta story and the
fact that we couldn't find our book like
we had people sprinting in the store
yeah fans they were there all right and
they were there looking for the book and
it's like we it was like there we were
so trying to like hide the goods so it's
kind of like when your kid comes out for
the Easter egg hunt I'm not done yeah it
was it was get back in the house it was
a little awkward and then after they got
their picture then they
kind of went over to the book section I
was like oh I guess they're they're the
ones there they're the one Stewart gonna
get the Polaroid which I didn't feel bad
about get out quicker but then the
interesting thing that happened Santa
doesn't want to be in the sack when the
kids wake up in the morning oh gosh
then when the fans got their picture
taking with us then the employees of
Walmart who had absolutely no idea who
we were just lined up one one after the
other they all wanted to get their
picture with it which I gotta think put
their jobs in jeopardy I mean they had
no idea who we were but yeah I was like
I think my granddaughter will care about
this and she and so she got a picture
and then somebody else got a picture and
somebody else got a picture and I was
like you guys have no idea who we are we
could be we could be serial killers of
course that probably wouldn't be while
somebody's getting a picture with us but
that would beyond we we took several
pictures with random Walmart employees
and then we're like guys we need to go
because we think more people are gonna
be showing up here and this is just
gonna get more awkward so we we walked
out but we did not find our book but we
did put the picture in a book called
side-chick which looked like a really
really good novel yeah he was by an
author called cat with two t's que ATT
but that was it no last name no first
name is just cat writing things like
side-chick i'm sure that he or she is I
got other books other than side-chick
I'm sure side-chick is just one of many
what's another ed pieces adventure that
we went on before the day before that in
Austin I mean we were I love Austin man
I gotta go back to Austin yeah great
that every time that's a fun little
place they got a bridge leading into
downtown across the river and that leads
to a statue of Willie Nelson which is
amazing and under that bridge is
according to my sources the like I think
the largest urban conglomerate of bats
fruit bats hiding I'm not hiding living
under the bridge and I mean they're
hiding most dusk every day
there's a mass exodus of bats that I've
seen on like nature shows that you can
go down to the banks of the river at
dusk and watch all these bats like
shorts start swirling around above the
river and then take off and if you have
radar vision it looks like a storm is
coming out from under the freaking
bridge man who's got radar vision the
people of Austin I think mm-hmm I don't
understand if you were looking on a
radar it would look like a storm
you mean like infrared like a weather
radar oh that but if you had that in
your eyes like if you had like a like a
you know like a snapchat filter that is
weather radar I think that's a good idea
I think that would be really
inconvenient for someone on the ground
like storms coming up how can you tell
well the same way you can tell except
I've got radar vision it's not really
helping me yeah it's just they look like
clouds still I think honor radar the
bats register as a storm that's what I'm
trying to say I I doubt that that's what
the guy you were there when the guy told
us he said that registers on the radar
yes I didn't hear that he made that part
up what will he said it I just I just
blend out fat so much that you didn't
want to even hear about this is a
misconception my wife that's one first
of all my wife just she just we brought
our wives with us don't bring my wife in
and it really it changed the complexion
of the trip quite a bit don't you think
but one of the ways that it changed the
complexion of the trip is that my wife
loves to just talk like typically if
Linc and I are in a car and there's like
an uber driver it's like I'll say like
hello I'm nice but I don't get into the
backstory I'm just I'm an introvert I
don't like to have that conversation but
my wife is an extrovert and so it's
funny in his funny this she's in the
very back and he's in the very front now
in the middle and let me tell you that
your wife did that I think your wife did
this more than my wife but they both did
it when you're what when our wives are
what I've noticed about them and I
notice about notice this about them like
seven times during the trip but your
wife more than my wife treated people
like they were
the Internet as if an internet didn't
exist right so it's like we've got this
guy driving us to the hotel and then
your wife starts asking him questions
about like where are the good
restaurants and all this stuff yeah and
it's this like I'm thinking well that's
what Yelp is for it's like I don't have
to have a conversation with one put one
person from one point of view when I can
have a conversation with like a thousand
people all at once through the internet
and you get using out of your thumbs get
the aggregate opinion of the people of
Austin without having an awkward
conversation but then now you got a
driver who's suddenly tour guide did you
know he drove over that bridge twice he
drove past our hotel we realized later
drove over the bridge just so he could
because he thought oh these ladies are
into me I'm gonna be the tour guide he's
like the fruit bats show up on the radar
there's the largest urban population of
fruit bats in America and then he drives
and then he goes around in a circle how
do you know he said that and then he's
like this is our Willie Nelson statue
that's a great restaurant and I'm
thinking like guys we could have we said
great somewhere but we a I want to be in
the hotel right now and be I could get
all this information from the internet
but then it happened again she asked
somebody else a question does she do
that all the time when y'all are
together well we don't typically ride
with strangers in other settings well my
wife also does that with what where I
was going with this is that what my wife
did with the bat guy with the driver is
that when he said the story about bats
she said well he's really scared of bats
talking about me and I'm not really
scared of bats there's just a bat that
lives in the awning above our jacuzzi at
home and and it and I got really scared
one time and fell down when the thing
flew at my head okay I fell down I'm
sorry
because I'm really close to the I'm
really close to the ceiling
but you were you've lived on Rhett you
fell down in fear I hid of course I did
because Heather Dinklage got bit by a
bat when I was a kid when we were all
out playing she got bit by freaking bat
it landed in her hair and it wouldn't
get out it's like slapping all around in
her hair your heads up in the nest yeah
and I'm like if a bats gonna land on
somebody's head whose head is it gonna
land on first my
so you're like spread-eagle on your
patio trying to get away from no I fell
backwards oh gosh I hit the deck and
then she started laughing I mean ever
since then she's like he's scared of
bats I'm like well I'm scared of
anything
flying mammal that gets within a foot of
my head yes I don't think but I'd watch
the fruit bats but as soon as they turn
I hit the deck you're afraid of bees two
men I am very scared of bees yeah and
that has nothing to do with any of this
yes you'll you'll your back spread for a
bee and anything that can fly and hurt
you you're afraid of yeah yeah well
there you go you're afraid of it I'm
afraid of it but not especially afraid
it's not a bad phobia actually I don't
have a phobia of bees I just very
uncomfortable around them is there a
difference yeah like oh okay no if you
got you you were debilitated if we never
had a that comes there if you had a bat
in a glass terrarium and you put it
right next to my face I wouldn't be
scared I feel like if you have a phobia
you'd be scared I feel like I have an
unnecessarily you have a practical fear
of you have a phobia of bat flight I
have a phobia of flying bats that are
open flying in the open well under an
awning but if I took it open if I took a
snake and put it in this jar and it was
clear and I held it up to your face
you'd be totally fine mm-hmm but would
you feel uncomfortable I would feel
uncomfortable see I feel like that's
different I feel like that's like a next
layer that's like getting into phobia I
first of all I don't believe you if I
had a bat in a terraria bring a bat in a
jar you and you will be on the jar you
bring it
you'll get that feeling in your balls
like when you walk to the edge of my
balls what when you walk to the edge of
a cliff and there's that sinking feeling
that you might vomit or doesn't happen
in my balls oh really talking about
every time I go to the edge of a cliff I
get a feeling of my loss like a sinking
feeling - tell that to your doctor
we just had a physical today not a
physical a very easy physical he did ask
me to coffee didn't grab any I noticed
that I was actually I was on my laptop
while you were getting the physical and
he's like please coughing oh my oh Sh
it's like I'm in the same room with you
and I think why did you look up because
I was like well I'm not gonna have to
get the balls out right here in front of
the link I mean we did to get the second
means together but he what why did he
ask you to coffee didn't ask me to call
I don't know he must have looked like he
must have thought I looked like I had
something lodged in my godness you have
something you need to cough up right now
so anyway but he was great having but
ladies with us and the thing that was
frustrated about I didn't want to drive
around downtown I wanted to get brisket
Yeah right
and we finally got to what's the name of
the place that we did I mean there's so
many places you can go that rubies are
Rudy's Rudy's and there's so many
different places in Austin you can go
it's and you're gonna fence I'm walking
around and and barbecue heaven but we
couldn't go do it so well so for the
sake of timing and location we went to
Rudy's the worst barbecue in Texas is
what their sign says and it's attached
this particular one is attached to a gas
station which I thought was cool yeah it
was it was bad Marco get that what's the
what's the fatty brisket brisket wet
brisket
it's the brisket with a little more fat
and then you get two pork ribs
I mean Kristi's from Kinston she's from
down east they del smoked a pork rib for
at the drop of a hat somebody's birthday
somebody gets married somebody dies look
cook a pig she knows some barbecue and
she's like yes maybe the best pork rib
I've ever had well they might concur
it is something that we don't do in
North Carolina yeah as like we don't
take pride in our brisket but so I
always got to get that and but I would
say a both brisket was as good as I've
had like I've had some really good
brisket almost wrong it's so good that
was really good but the ribs
specifically first of all you got it if
you want to really enjoy barbecue you
especially a rib it's not a sauced rib
like when you go to when you go to like
Chili's or Applebee's and they give you
the baby back ribs and there
slathered in sauce like guys that's not
a rib a rib is a dry rub ribs that
doesn't have any sauce on it and you're
actually tasting the meat yeah and if
it's smoked it's not boiled it's not
baked slow slow and slow smoked and
there's this I don't know how they did
it they have it where it has the taste
and like smoke ring of a smoked rib but
the tenderness of one that has been
baked like it's fall it's not quite
falling off the bone but it is so it
comes off clean oh my good man it was a
heavenly experience hey you know when I
met a low point I'm a think about that
brisket well we could get some shipped
here you know what to just think about
it I think just thinking about it will
be powerful enough for me thinking about
it makes me want it I'm getting them
starving right you've just created want
with yourself but I'm gonna go back to
that moment and let me tell you if you
walk in a restaurant and you look in the
back corner of the main dining hall and
there is a trough where multiple people
can wash their hands at once you know
you're in the right spot and right I had
that freaking trough they had a device a
device that was two holes and you
thought it was a dishwashing thing I no
no no I thought it was a hand dryer like
you know how those like Dyson blades you
like you put you I was like oh this is a
new thing Oh hand dryer you wash your
hand in the big trough sink and then you
put your hands in these two holes
because someone had I saw someone with
their hands in the holes yeah and I was
like oh you wash and you dry your hands
in this newfangled version of a hand
dryer but it wasn't it was a hand washer
and it was the most it was it was almost
sensual you'd stick your hands in there
come on and the water starts going and
it's warm and there's soap in it and
it's it's spaced in such a way that the
soapy water is lower than the rents
water really yes
so you stick it in there and there's
like I was sanitizing thing what
happening and you go deeper there's jets
all around the thing I would say there's
about 40 Jets it's like the freaking
Jetsons around around your hole and you
can you can go all the way up to your
shoulder into this thing no you can go
almost to your elbow it's not like
delivering a baby cow but you can I mean
cuz sometimes when you eat ribs and you
know if you hold him like this long
enough you're gonna get you're gonna get
drip all the way down the forearm and
they take that into account it was a it
was a and then as you it was a sensual
expect exactly it was this warm water
and as you pulled it out there's like a
curtain of rinse water that just rinsed
all the soap off and I was like and then
I was like where are the dry holes where
are the drier holes and they didn't have
dry it has drawn your house I mean I
think those are your pockets
I think 2018 they'll get dryer holes
there well it should the water should
turn off and then the air should turn on
well and then you should pull it out in
the future bathroom sinks are just gonna
be a wall of holes oh good and you just
stick your hands in these two holes and
you stick your hands in these two holes
and that's it I think probably toilets
will be that - yeah restrooms will just
be a serious sort of wall of holes and
you just gotta go up we have seen the
future we know for certain wall of holes
that's it you know what that was amazing
I got an idea we open a restaurant I've
not seen that anywhere else
we call it hole in the wall oh and then
people come in and but this is real
fancy like yeah the hole in the wall has
nothing to do with the decor it has to
do with the bathroom the bathrooms are
just holes in the wall so you reach your
hand in and you pull out brisket is it
in the dining room - my gosh yes the
whole restaurant everywhere the whole
restaurant is holes hole in the wall
hole in the wall yeah that's how you get
your food that's how you pay that's how
you wash that's how you tinkle yeah it's
an entirely anonymous existence all
holes in the wall there's no tables or
anything but it's a very tastefully
that's the subtitle hole in the wall a
very tasteful experience it's very
tasteful everything about it is tasteful
right I should go back to New York I got
a show know New York
a little love of course we went there
first and before the inaugural stop on
the tour of mythicality which was in
Huntington Long Island we had to make a
few pyaara stops including the the Ryan
and Kelly show the Kelly & Ryan show
Kelly Kelly live with Kelly and Ryan
yeah many weeks back now maybe maybe you
saw that but um first time we were on
there Ryan Seacrest was absent you know
the guy from American Idol I know him I
felt like I knew him really well because
like I watched a lot of American Idol
from like season two to like like back
in the day like me and Christy we would
like Tut we would time the changing of
our kids diapers in like season 2 season
3 of American Idol because we you we
didn't have TiVo and you couldn't pause
it and we were that into American I
first few seasons in a run and I got to
run and change the baby's diaper I
remember that in a commercial break for
American Idol that's how into it we were
and I just thought Ryan was just he's
always been excellent at it I would
thought he was just great he is the kind
of guy that you feel like you know
because you've seen him so many times
yeah I think people may feel that way
about us and you know what I'm honored
to be if I'd love to be mistaken for
Ryan Seacrest one day any day of the
week every day of the week um we didn't
you don't think you wouldn't know no
you're taller than him I'm a lot taller
than him we didn't meet him before the
show and of course we met Kelly last
time she's she's she's great she's she's
personal friend now no we we've taken
pictures with her and her son is a good
to go beast yeah well you did sign a
book first huh
but we didn't see Ryan until we like
walked out and we were actually doing
the show and I'm like this is cool you
know it's weird how you're when you're
thinking things about like oh I'm I'm
meeting Ryan Seacrest I remember I used
to change the baby's diapers and
commercial break for America not I'm
thinking all this while we're actually
yeah well that we're on live television
yeah 100% I know my mom's watching and
I'm thinking like yeah if you ever see
his nose looked
different in person than it does on
television I'm literally thinking oh no
a hundred percent like I think that you
know hopefully it's not obvious if you
watch you go back and watch this it's
like I'm thinking all the same things
you're not thinking about what you're
supposed to be thinking about like and
that's no excuse for why I spilled the
whole smoothie all over the table I did
that for comedic effect
okay that was purposeful but you're
thinking about the experience that
you're having I'm well that's good I I
feel like it's good to be in the moment
that you can we can do that like oh I'm
assessing Ryan Seacrest well knows
location but there's things like that
but there's also like oh this is
interesting there's alive even though
this is the second time we've been on
the show so like there's this is live
and there's an audience here right now
and like I'm kind of trying to make them
laugh but I really should be thinking
about the people who are watching at
home and like you're having all these
thoughts as you're doing it and then I
like I you know we did the thing and
then I I called Jesse and I'm like do
you see did you watch it and she's like
yeah um you swayed a lot swayed you
swayed a lot like are you talking about
like a like a palm tree in the corner of
your yard
she's like you were kind of like that
mother neighbor you were swaying back
and forth quite a bit and I was like you
really got to stop that red and I was I
had I was swaying what I was doing is I
was doing I was having the thoughts that
you're talking about I was thinking
about oh we're on the show and we got to
move things along we got to be funny but
I'm thinking about all I'm seeing Ryan
Seacrest for the first time that causes
me to sway apparently do it a little it
was it like a dancing kind of swing low
like you're listening in the REO
speedwagon it was like it was like I'm
ready for action kind of like I think it
was my attempt to be energetic because I
have a tendency to just be pro so it was
an athletics way it was like a weight
shifting so that you can like dodge a
hook you be ready for anything
but I'm such a large individual and I
had on a jacket so I think when I start
swaying like that like it's there's like
a bell effect that happened mm-hmm
I mean hey I start I create a breeze a
noticeable breeze and B it's you can't
help
but notice it it's like putting a ruler
in front of your your computer screen
and just going like this it's gonna you
can't me I had a pink jacket on there's
almost seven feet tall swinging back and
forth like a [ __ ] I'm sorry I did it I
mean you know what I'm when she told me
that I'm like that's all you got to say
but then I was like you know what and
she's like you did great you just swayed
a lot I was like I'm actually happy you
told me that because I'm not gonna swing
it in fact I've been going to have on
whose and I just said I want you to do
something to my hip so I can't sway oh
you know I work worked thus way out I
think she's trying to do the opposite
actually wants to loosen all of that up
she didn't tension in the hips she's way
into the neighbors attention
we met Ryan Seacrest assistant who after
the bit we got her we got our pictures
with both of them and then I think this
was afterward she comes in with a couple
of boxes for us my bags with boxes at
her she's like Ryan wanted me to give
these to you guys and we're opening it
up immediately oh nice she's like it's
it's his skincare line for men and it
was a box with like I can't remember
what the brand was a doctor somebody it
doesn't say Ryan Seacrest I just think
he must have like a sponsorship deal
with this like skincare for men I'm like
wait wait wait wait wait I got like a
skin care regimen now like you don't
have to Christie oh I've been using it I
brought you haven't been using it I
broke this thing out and I left my own
there's three two online link yeah well
I uh I've made fun of Christie for like
years because she has this like here's
my nighttime skin regimen and here's my
morning skin regimen there's like I
can't make sense of what's on her sink
and what's in the shower there's like
like seemingly three versions of the
same thing then if you read the fine
print it's like step one nighttime was
like Step five midnight step nine and
I'm early morning cream and I didn't
know I would react this way but then
when
Seacrest gave me my own skincare regimen
I was very happy about it I was like I
have a three-step skincare regimen now
I've been doing that I've been doing
something similar for like two years now
really no seriously look tell me about
it no the first one is like rubbing
lotion tea dirt all over your face it's
like it's foliage all right exfoliating
man and then you wash that off and then
the second data funny to hear and he's
old man talk about exfoliation creamed
like it's a it's a new invention and
then the second one oh did you hear that
it was uh it's these headphones if you'd
have heard that it was it's like
scraping a brisket across Ryan Seacrest
face that's what I just heard I I heard
it I heard it as well I did not have his
visceral reaction you know if it was a
bat it was like I would have been on my
back I am afraid of Ryan Seacrest
brisket face that's my you better tell
me that the third step is brisket second
I'm second step man is pork ribs shave
cream plus soap it's like face wash that
then you shave off instead of rinse off
are you sure you read that right yes I
have to read it every time cuz they all
look the same and I don't want to do
them out of order you're shaving your
forehead again I don't I just I washed
the part of my face that I shave and
then I'm most concerned about what about
the other parts and then the last thing
is lotion for the face it's pretty
revolutionary
we've got exfoliation cream shaving
cream and lotion so man and then it's
and I put that everywhere and it's got
an SPF in it and it feels like I'm
putting on sunscreen well cuz that's
what SPF is and I I just think when
you're as old as we are me you and Ryan
how old is Ryan Seacrest older than us
but not by much 58 43 42 yeah he's 42
see we got to care about these things
all right I trust
well no but I've been I seriously I have
this I I started this a couple years ago
because well I get that everyone always
tells me that I look tired and guys I
don't look tired I look old that's you
just need to get more specific that's
that's what's happening to me I'm aging
I'm 40 years old I'm not gonna look like
not me I'm using my regimen man no so
but I was like and also my eyes are like
big and buggy and and like and also when
like this is a perfect example like on
on camera you got lights that are coming
down and also your eyeball itself
creates a shadow that's how much it bugs
out and push I'm in talking to have on
about that because way she has to pull
on the middle she like grab no she just
grabs your face and this with her thumbs
she never does it direct she'll like
give me a wet willy I've also go in now
because I'm gonna partly blame you for
this because you've got glasses and we
can't have a light that reflects and so
we have to have a light that is high
enough so that it doesn't reflect in
links glasses and that creates this
situation where I've got these bags so
I've got these big exposed eyeballs and
sometimes my bags are really really
kicking in yeah we have the opposite my
eyes are so deep it's like lavon's push
them all the way in we need to tell her
we need to tell it that we need a happy
medium right we need to go in together
we need to hug both of it because of
that I have like gain I have a two-step
process no I put this in the morning I
do this what's on that one what's in the
night mmm well I do like a retina based
thing which is like acne well helps with
acne but it helps with like
discoloration and like you know as you
start getting older you get like weird
spots on your face and stuff like that
so it keeps that from happening and then
the eye gel keeps from the bags man it's
like I got to do it in the morning right
before we shoot and even though I still
do that it still looks like if you go
back five years you can be like oh yeah
he's getting old he's getting old but
all that stuff is whoo dude man no it's
not i J first of all what is hoodoo did
you mean voodoo no voodoo
it's a term but it's no it's not man
next time you're in an uber ask him what
I'm saying is that stuff is it's
legitimate man you the one that just
told me about your
we step process you think all that's
hoodoo yeah but I just love to do it cuz
it seems like I'm procedure in myself
there's no doubt that putting some
lotion on your on your skin helps
yeah but stave off the aging process
absolutely no doubt it's been
scientifically proven have you well my a
commercial my actions in my emotion
speak louder than my words yeah but I've
been doing that process man I I swallow
my pride a long time ago you hear enough
comments about something and then you
start doing something about it next time
I see Ryan Seacrest I'm gonna be like
Ryan I've been using your skin regimen
he's gonna be like well I don't good for
you he does I use the expensive stuff
that's what he's gonna tell you oh no I
think I believe in my heart that I have
a connection with him every time I face
you think Ryan Seacrest is sitting
around shaving his whole face just to
wash it he's not doing that it's a prank
man
there's probably a camera in that third
step like how many people are gonna
think that we can actually put shaving
cream and soap together in one product
explain the camera I'm saying that the
whole system is an elaborate prank on
people like you and like four years from
now there's gonna be a compilation video
on Jimmy Kimmel this is gonna be a bunch
of people washing and shaving their face
at the same time and you're gonna be the
star of it okay I'm fine with it if that
means I can have yours your box well I
do want to test it I might add one of
the steps to my 2-step since you got
three steps all I got two steps I feel
like I need another step mmm definitely
I got a washing shave him I don't shave
it all we could and then you know we're
gonna invent like a mythical face
regimen of course sad of course lates
men yeah but it's gonna involve we need
to risk it juice we need to do a team a
teen acne brisket juice regimen yeah
step one is rubbing brisket step two is
you just eat pork ribs just because you
can experience the sound of brisket
rubbing across your face just like Ryan
Seacrest does I bet you a brisket on the
face would help with acne something
about the fats something about it yeah
well I give you a youthful glow all
right guys we're gonna tweak it we're
going to go into R&D at a mythical
entertain
and we won't burden you with the details
until it's it's fully fleshed out thank
you for listening and thank you for
letting us know what you think about
your biscuits using hashtag ear biscuits
I regularly go on the Twitter and look
up the hash tag of your biscuits to see
what you guys think yeah so thank you
for doing that and then he tells me
about it we talked about it yeah
sometimes I'll search it too that's why
there's two of us
[Music]